[Music]
we have two
talks Thank you for would like to Thank
the organizers for inviting me here so
I'm going to Present this work that done
together with People here Mario Alvin
Carol Morgan costas
cholis annab and Jeff
Smith let
me  bri Is going to be about so going to
be about quantitative information Flow
Which is a way to measure the leakage of
sensitive information in computer System
and the motivations for this Work is
that been Well This is rather Old Field
Through The Years been a lot of  leakage
measures that have been proposed with
different properties
and
Notar to choose and also There is no
Clear relation among them so One Step
Forward to try to organize this Field
was done by cof and Basin in already
Almost 10 years ago because they
actually said that Well  you don't need
to choose because In fact different
measures correspond to
different operational have different
operational interpretations so They
correspond to different kind of
adversary so really depends on the Model
of adversary that you want to
have Still the relations between them
and the Models of  adversary is not has
not been investigated so the reason why
we did this Work assomatic
is to try to capture the Concept of
vulnerability or Which is at the basis
of information
leakage through some intuitive and
General properties and also to try to
figure out the dependencies  among These
properties and in Parallel as actually
as a prior work We had studied a Sort of
generalization of the notion of
leakage aiming obtaining a General
notion that
would would particular cases the
Var entropy Stud in literature But also
possibly capture also other other New
Models  of adversaries So we developed
this framework that We call G
vulnerability where the different
adversaries are represented by a
parameter parameter g Which stands for a
Gain function which
represents the goal of the adversary and
the way he measures
that developed completely
independently to our Surprise We turned
out that G leakage G vulnerability
is the characterization of this Class of
axioms that we have studied so Sound
complete with respect to this
axati So This is the the Plan of the
Talk We first speak a little bit about
the background represent the so
information theoretical approach  to
quantitative information Flow and then I
will introduce the notion of the leckage
and then finally the axiomatization So
let me start with the background um so
First of all What is a secret so I'm
going to speak about um lage Secrets
Well Secret is can  be anything in this
framework We try to be very
abstract so for instance can be a
password can be a location or can be Key
cryptographic Key any Any Kind of Value
That is considered
sensitive and Of course We will have a
set of values ​​for this Secret  Which Will
indicate by x and we assume
That the adversary has some Guess about
the Secrets represented in terms of
probability
Distribution so Which We call prior
probability Distribution prior In The
sense That is what the adversary knows
about the secret before observing
anything about the
System I  will use the word usually
represent this prior with the letter
pi Now
System we want to study the leakage the
System so System is in this information
theoretical interpretation is represented
as a Channel an information theoretical
Channel where the the inputs are the
Secrets the values ​​of the  Secrets and
the outputs are Whatever we can observe
from the System so can be for instance
the result of a computation but can also
be physical characteristics like I don't
know the time of decryption you know
because want to Capture
which is considered the output of  the
System and
normally this System will be
probabilistic
behavior Reason is
because inst
mechanism
privacy
is Noise Add purpose to try to
make confuse the
adversary so in General there will be a
probability Distribution associated to
any input Which is the conditional
probability
of
action is important  is Matrix the
conditional probabilities so in General
we don't want to look at the physical
characteristics of the channel We just
want to look at the abstraction in terms
of Matrix and all the properties that
that are interesting from the Point of
View of information Flow
are Based on
Matrix
of
yend X
Y the prior is not sorry the
of System is that
the probability distributions the
conditional probability distributions
are Independent from the prior This is
atic information thetic
channels Us
me we can Mod properties that are
Independent from the input
Distribution properties of the System in
a sense and they depend on the data In
which  the System Will Run
upon so quantitative information What is
the problem
intu The problem is that we want
limiter
Secret
in
General the reason
Why adversary gains Knowledge
about Secret by obing the observables is
that Thanks to the theorem after serv
particular Val
the
System prior Distribution changes  into
so posterior Distribution Which is Which
Gives the adversary a better hint a
better Guess about the True Value of the
secret in average So This means that
Maybe Sometimes the output Will confuse
the adversary but
average
Nothing the output of the
System So let me give  an
example This Is My Favorite example is
the soed dining cryptographer Net by CH
was Given was invented a long time ago
so the idea
is that There is a set of noes users
that want to participate
Anonymous
anon
protocol There is a set of users that
agree  to participate in this protocol
the idea is
that one Node May want to communicate to
broadcast A bit of information and you
Wanted to do it in an anonymous way in
The sense That
the
Value this bit Should be known
communs obs not isde is the user That  is
transmitting
information the Source information must
anonymous for instance could here that
to
sendit
anon was to
associate Sorry forgot to say that We
assume that in this the set of users
communicate with Each other via binary
channels so They constitute a Graph and
is not necessarily full  Graph can be a
very Spar Graph but the important Thing
is that
Connect
Ass
and
edes Channel two users We
associate binary Coin and then the Coins
get toed
someh
and the protocol at this
Point Works in this way Each Node
computes the
the co
arent and then  if don't have not the
ones That transmit the information Just
compute the binary Sum and declare make
a declaration declaration to the outside
World about the binary
Sum the sender The One thats to send the
information Do The Thing but the
end
B
and Will also  declare his Value now the
protocol achieves goal of communicating
the Value B outside
Because the outside observer to know the
Value of B will have just to make the
binary Sum all the declaration of all
the nodes and the result will be exactly
B Can you
why why
B cancel right because Each Coin is
counted twice because incident so the
binary the Coins will be Zero so the
result will be Just the the bit added by
this
user Now we want I want to Show How we
can Model this protocol on the as a
Channel  as an information theoretical
Channel so the Secrets here are the
identity is the identity of the Node
broadcast the
protocols are are the declarations of
the users so assume that
the observer Can Only see the
declaration of the users cannot see Of
course Who is the broadcast Sorry  Who is
the culprit and cannot see the Value of
the Coins and very important does know
what is happening exactly Inside the
protocol
forg to say that in General assumes That
the adversary knows the
Matrix of the probabilities the
conditional
probabilities does know the single
values ​​Used During  the execution but He
knows He knows the
Distribution
formability Distribution all the users
tos What is the probability that the is
that particular
Node and the goal of the adversary after
declaration is to try to infer Who is
the culprit by using the posterior
Distribution that he gets  at that
Point so Make the
calculation on R here i as
example
Gra That is actually Ring of three
noes and assume That the bit is one the
Value of the bit to be transmitted is
one
so the kind of Matrix that We obtain
depends On the Value  Sorry depends on
the probability distributions on the
Coins if the Coins are Fair and the
Graph
connected sry and the Gra is connected
Which is the case here
because we Get a Matrix of This kind
compute all the probabilities we find
out
That the Matrix is ​​very symmetric  namely
every declaration for every possible
culprit all the declarations are
possible with the same
probabilities the possible declarations
are only Those of Which
[Music]
the I
can number of And there
ispc No actually no So we assume
Yes the answer to first Question is Yes
we  assume the adversary no the topology
but It doesn't Help if the Graph is Fly
is connected not Fully connected if It
is
connected
It's and the
Coins Fair
anous
declaration can
EXP yeah
essentially the reason is
that I didn't explain We Get believe me
that We get this
Matrix
all the outputs are given with the same
probabilities There is intuitive there is
no reason
to attribute the more probability I mean
except for the prior Of course if prior
is already Bed
then you Put Your bet on on the one with
probability
uni any declaration also for symmetry
Reasons There is no reason
to attribute more probability to One the
than the
others On The
Others then it becomes more interesting
Because in this case The Matrix is ​​not
symmetric Well [
Music]
not the Point is
that for each
elys
ver When you look at the output there
are some inputs that are More likely than
other Right so so It's intuitive That
the adversary Will Gain Something by
Knowing the exact output
Right the reason why we obtain a Matrix
of this form Of course the more the
probability
the more Lik That the de is the one that
sending bit that's the reason Why the
diagonal
here higher than the other
values ​​Right Let me show you how the
prior changes to posterior Maybe you
know
this Quick
meev is more likely to be the The Other
two  Ok so way to compute the posterior
is to calculate the joint
probabilities can doly
mping
Mat then you compute the marginals on
the observables and then depending on
the observable that you get suppose for
instance you get 00 then by applying the
bias theorem you compute the probability
of Each of these nodes to be the culprit
Given this particular
observable Now why we are doing All this
Well because there useful concepts that
we can borrow from information Theory
that can be useful for modeling the
leakage of information so There is this
famous notion of entropy  which
represents
the which represents the degree of
uncertainties of event of a Random
variable and we can use it to measure
the vulnerability of the secret namely
How likely It is that the
adversary guesses discovers The
Secret and another important Concept is
that of Mutual information expr the
degree probabilistic correlation between
the input and the
output
[Music]
and the idea is that When
you Well you have this Concept of prior
entropy That is the prior the entropy of
the secret before you run the channel
and then after you know the particular
Value output  the channel computes the
posterior entropy and then by taking
entropy the input after the output is in
General defined as the average the
posterior entropy that you get on the
particular values ​​and that is the
entropy of X After
Y
correlation
information between prior and posterior
entropies and  if you If
You If you think What if if your goal is
to Express the leakage that is due to
the
System It's intuitive that you that you
have to subtract the Knowledge That the
the adversary already has about the
secret right because That's not the
fault of  the System So What we want to
model leakage is exactly this difference
between the posterior Knowledge and pror
Knowledge and quantities by the way can
be computed assuming that you know the
prior and you know the Matrix of
conditional
probabilities So let me spend a few
Words about  this operational
interpretation because
it
How to use information Theory Everybody
more Less agreed but there Were a lot of
different ideas about what Concept of
entropies one should use because Well
already in the literature of information
Theory different notions of entropy
shanon entropy is the most famous One
Real
Security The Beginning People
Us Shannon Theory Sorry Shannon entropy
but was not
convincing People proposing different
notions
and finally
cofin
develop
posterior
Time the
fool
and and then we
define particular adversary as the kind
of questions that can Ask and the way
measures Attack the success the  Attack
in General We consider rational
adversaries namely the adversary Will
Try To maximize
success measure of success forance
if
assume is Secret satisf
property and the measure of success is
the expected number of questions That
the needs to Ask in Order to completely
figure out the Value of  the
secret
then make a
Search Search Space that completely
Split at each question Each Time He asks
A Question he asks it in Such a way that
the weight of the probabilities
Split as in as much as possible so
for instance in this example here you
will organize the questions by asking
first if Secret is in this set here
because
If the answer is Yes and if answer is no
in both cases the
remaining the two sets that he Has to
look for the secret will be Split will
be two sets of equal  probability
Ok now the measure of success Said is
the average number of questions the
expected number of questions that we
have to ask to arrive to to a Lea right
now the measure of
success the length Sorry the length of a
Path to Leaf You can see that  since The
Three is organized in this way the
length will be the inverse of
probability or an approximation of it so
you can see What is the notion of
entropy what is so the measure of
success Remember is the expected number
length Node
Path
le log invers
probability
meure
entropy theed length is Given by formula
that corresponds to the formula of
shanon
entropy
Sorry
problem video
RAM as Said entr was not the
only
notion particular The Most Famous the
most popular ones Guess in
entropy AND bias vulnerability Gu in
entropy is essentially considering
questions the
form is this the Value of the secret is
the Sec is the Value of the secret equal
V and the
adversary Has to Discover The Secret the
is to Discover The Secret enti
aage
numbered number of questions to
Ask in the best possible
strategy vulnerability is the con  bi
Risk
simp Sec In just one
Try asking the form is this the Value of
the secret and Of course again will try
the best strategy so it is it amounts to
the Max to the Maximum probability of
the the Element that That is more likely
to to  the probability of the Element
Maximum probability and this is
correlated to the mean entropy
Ok
so Ok so The problem is what about
different operational scenario and that
brings me to the second part of the Talk
Jesus Time passes
quickly so
essentially the notions that considered
in literature  we are very limited
in General The advers Wanted to know the
Value of the secret but there are many
other situations In which the adversary
might Gain Something even without
discovering The Secret entirely so For
instance You might be interested in
guessing Part Of The Secret or guessing
approximately The Secret Like in the
case of location privacy for instance or
guessing property of the secret And So
on and example
a number of
triad the
secret thee When you try to
break Credit Card by guessing the PIN
code So This br to consider the
framework of  G leakage where the
adversary is modeled by G functions
Which are the G
function How the
Secret G is function from gess and Real
values
to a number in
R and G
vulnerability
measures as the expected gain of the
adversary When makes
When he maximizes the Such amount  and
the interesting Point about This is that
all the examples that I showed
in Previous slide can be modeled by a
suitable g function and also the various
notions that have been studied in the
literature can also Be shown to Be
instances of this
framework Now  This is all what I want to
say about G leakage let me pass now to
the somatization Which is the most
interesting part
so First of
all need to briefly introduce Den
notation of Hyper distributions so
channels can be seen as a transformation
from a prior to a  set
of Distribution That the
posteriors
and can often We Get That is
not Essential like in this case for
instance We Get two columns Which are
exactly the same I mean Sorry two two
posteriors Which are exactly the same in
correspondence of Two different outputs
so from the  Point of View of information
leakage It's not really important that
one is called the y2 and the other is
called the y3 What is important is the
weight of the probability by Which We
get
this particular posterior so
column and the probability and this is
what we Call  Hyper distributions so In
Other Words a Channel transforms One
probability Distribution into a set of
into a distributions over probability
distributions So I will use
this not here to Den Hyper
Distribution And I will use the brackets
Around One Distribution to to denote the
Point Hyper Distribution and  the most
important One is this notation that is
represen the Distribution That is the
result
of applying C to a particular
prior This is representation of What
Happens
is the initial Distribution the prior
This
is an
example probability Distribution on a
set of three Elements so It's a  Simplex
When I Push the prior to the Matrix what
I obtain
is in this case three posteriors with
different
weights the Size corresponds to the
probability
sets conve set the
pri and C the Ideal
figure
So let me Skip
This just to explain that have the
prior if  already
defed our prior vulnerability is there
is there standard way to obtain a
posterior
Well the way has been done in All cases
in the Past is to define the posterior
the
average
expectation the Hyper and that That is
what we do as
Well
[Music]
Now  so the reason why we did this Work
is to try to
organize try to
put to figure out some structure in this
zo notions that
Been
P We Wanted Try toive the notion
vulnerability by
considering Generic General and
intuitive principles so the first
principle We consider was the  continuity
a prior vulnerability Should Be a
continuous function of
the
Distribution
initiation Close to Each other the gain of
the adversary Should Be also very
close the second principle is that of
convexity so the vulnerability Should Be
a convex function of the Distribution
and Intuition is
that  If you have different priors and
and you Attack the secret
by using different pri and then you
combine
gains Way Should Be Better Than
combining the pri first and then making
the bet because When you combine to
Distribution that always generates
Confusion Now One the first result that
I wanted to Show you is that the G
functions are In fact complete
characterization ofz In The sense
That for every for every notion of
vulnerability that satisfies these
axioms There
is there is a g function that
corresponds to that notion and And then
it's also Sound In The  sense that
vulnerability does satisfy the
axium finally Can I have Still two
minutes
finally for the posterior we have
considered the following principles the
non interference Which says that if the
Matrix is ​​non interfere if the channel is
interference in the S That the prior the
posterior uncorrelated  then what we
Get if and
condition that's the case if and only
theor is the
Distribution
cases
weity of the the
Princip
is
from
System Vab
sec
vulnerability
before and finally the data Processing
inequality says that If we do post
Processing is a little bit
like What we  have in differential
privacy If we do post Processing that
does not Add anything to the Knowledge
of the secret so If we apply
Another Channel after the channel C We
Can Only Lose Knowledge the Can Only
lose can
anything and finally the Lasting The
Last axium that I  want to Show isx that
correlate correlates the prior to the
posterior and says that the posterior
Should Be defined as the
expectation on the Hyper
Distribution now the interesting Thing
is that if weing it turns out of all
namely monotonicity negativity convexity
and data Processing inequality are
equivalent  justifies the
conve
natural
out
Time Just Show the SLS the SL and Stop
Thank
you so Now we actually have a discuss
and so i Guess we can
possibly clarify questions and then go
to a more Open discussion so